sex is exercised in case you didn't know
it a new study out of the University of
Quebec at Montreal took a look at sex as
a form of exercise and they compared sex
to jogging walking uphill and playing
tennis they looked at 21 young straight
couples so I'm not sure what this means
for gay sex
they had them jog on treadmills for 20
minutes while researchers monitored
their energy expenditure in order to
provide a comparison or the physical
demands of sex and then if you're
wondering how they gauge how much how
many calories they burned during sex the
scientists gave volunteers an
unobtrusive arm band to monitor the
exertion and the calories that were
burned during sex according to the study
sex is the equivalent of playing doubles
tennis or walking up though okay pretty
good sex burn 4 calories per minute for
men and 3 minutes for women during
sessions that rain from 10 to 57 minutes
including foreplay
the average was 25 minutes men burned
about 9 calories per minute jogging and
women about seven so obviously the first
question here is how important is sex to
your physical fitness do you make it
part of your workout routine no I do not
consider it like oh I had sex with my
husband last night that's like going to
the gym but we're gonna skip it tonight
first of all who paid for this report
who paid for the research to find people
that fund the universe people realizing
why McDonald's is bad for you really
sexy of course you're gonna burn some
calories you're sweating your heartbeats
up do we really need to know that it's
four calories per day wanted to actually
quantify and put some numbers - I mean
we've known this before but this is a
new and ingenious way measuring up
having sex is like playing doubles
tennis do I need to know that no I've
noted these the people that came up with
this well I just think it's a study that
you know can you put this money towards
finding a cure for cancer oh come on
look at who actually funded the study
but I wouldn't be surprised if folks
like say viagra use these results to say
see you know this is like a gym
membership yeah is this one of these
things that we're so afraid to talk
about sex but if we weren't afraid to
talk about it people would be having
more sex and maybe being healthier
because of these benefits in case you
don't have access to a tennis court I
just don't really see people you're both
married if your husband came home and
said you know I ate like crap today and
I feel I just feel I don't feel great
and I go and I don't want to go to the
gym it's cold out and blah blah blah you
know can we do it for a couple hours
would you see that as well certainly you
probably wouldn't be laying down doing
it you know the old-fashioned way
because if you need to burn some
calories you're not going to gym you
better you better get up and start
moving around well you could lie man
burn a few more calories than women
because guys are doing most of the work
they I you're crazy
first of all um but you know come on
people you should be having sex for
enjoyment there's so many other things
than just burning calories it makes you
feel better it clears your mind you know
they say orgasms promote good health and
you feeling bad or a little too if this
helps folks that were maybe on on the
edge there and we're not sure they
wanted to participate if that helps them
by golly honey more to talk for al-qaeda
we're having more sex they might
probably would like to kill people less
because they'd be happier they're
satisfied and calm they have a you know
they can be home yeah Bill Maher has
said many times that in these countries
that repress all this sex stuff
all you're doing you're creating fertile
ground for terrorism because you're
you're denying and base in these
countries I've been to Afghanistan and
Pakistan and a lot of most of the Middle
East and you see it you're walking down
and I'm covered modestly and they're
still you see it in their eyes they
almost don't know they're looking at you
now remember a cartoon and you you look
at an animal but you just see the the
you know the chicken and the meat with
the bones that's what I feel like
they're looking at but you feel the
angst and the anger almost you know and
I was just thinking God if you got laid
you would just feel so much better
you're thinking that it I mean it
honestly it's with all the information
we have and everyone has you know
Twitter and all that even just last
night the Supreme Court in India
outlawed gay sex so why do things still
keep moving backwards India's a pretty
Western country even though it's in that
part of the world so why do things still
move backwards
it's basically there's you know that
that's the foundation of all repression
and suppression pretty much if you look
at the books on a lot of states in a lot
of America we still got some crazy crazy
you know
sodomy is outlawed in most southern
states still and I mean even consensual
sex with chickens is outlaw you know
there's there's still weird things on
the books that people don't necessarily
follow it's like arbitrary laws more
moralistic authoritarian tendency in our
society I think is partly what is behind
that we say if it's behind my four walls
in my house and I'm not hurting anybody
else just leave me alone you can't
regulate me inside my home you can't
regulate me inside my home a good finish
so get out there and have some
consensual sodomy you sodomite you crazy
side of my
[Music]